all right welcome welcome we are going
to have what I think will be a very
interesting conversation today I am
going to be joined momentarily by you
may know him as destiny you actually may
know him by any number of names if you
ever look at the chat during his live
streams but I won't be using any of
those others know him as Steven bunnell
how you doing man great to have you here
I'm doing great how you done good so
we're gonna eventually get to sort of
like the meat of this conversation which
will include the last time we talked we
kind of left off with the fact that we
don't
apparently fully agree about the use of
of lobbying advertisers to boycott
programs we'll get to that we'll talk
about platforming I'm curious my views
have continued to evolve on the issue of
platforming I'm curious whether whether
yours have but if people are not
familiar with you are you you you were
on Twitter I think you're still kicked
off Twitter right um that is correct but
I have a friend that posts on Twitter
and he posts a lot of really cool things
that I've got to agree with yeah that's
fair but so people are your biggest
following is is on twitch is that fair
to say
yeah for sure I actually have been
thinking about whether I should be doing
stuff on Twitch people sometimes write
to me and they say David you know
instead of streaming on YouTube you
should stream on Twitch and my reaction
is usually I don't have any followers on
Twitter I just be starting from zero
like is there any reason you can think
of I just now start on Twitch
I mean cross-pollination across
platforms is always a good business
venture I mean like there are people
that watch twitch they don't necessarily
watch YouTube even if you streamed and
only picked up like a few hundred live
viewers on Twitch I mean one you've got
a big following on YouTube that you can
already use to build a following on
Twitch and to any new viewers you pick
up on Twitter people that might not have
ever necessarily discovered you on
YouTube I think for the business point
of view spreading out to different
platforms is almost always a good
decision as long as you're not
compromising anything that you're
currently on to do it what on the
Gaffney's yeah maybe I should look you
would I have to do like I just never
watch twitch would I have to be doing
drastically different things than what
I'm doing now
um the bar for like twitch content is
much lower than like the bar for like
YouTube stuff so as long as when I don't
let me explain that when I say that like
like you can do you can stream whatever
on Twitch you doesn't have to be like
super super formal or anything I know
that people usually set a lot higher
standard for their YouTube stream so
yeah I mean you can get whatever you
stream on YouTube is almost for sure
gonna be fine for twitch alright well if
if there's continued interest I guess I
will make an account on Twitch and start
to figure figure out what it what
exactly it is I would be doing there so
you have um yeah I I think there's a I
don't know what program you guys use but
there should be literally a way to sigh
most REME like you should be able to
just push one button and have the
identical stream that you're swimming on
YouTube go right to twitch as well like
that should be and you don't even have
to think about it you know see now that
actually sounds interesting I you we are
the live streams I use OBS which I think
I think what I would have to do is just
add a secondary stream address and then
I might be able to actually stream to
both of them yep I'm pretty I'm almost
positive you do them on OBS so I know
you could at one point in time so yeah
so listen last time you were on neither
of us made a pilgrimage to the bond
Studios in Los Angeles which is where
Jesse Lee petersen films and records his
radio show and his TV program and all of
this stuff so you you went out there
how did were you going to be in LA
already and they somehow reached out to
you or did they actually invite you out
um I actually moved to the LA area so
that I could do like live content and
stuff and I guess when they found out I
was out here they reached out and yeah I
went on the show so what the what struck
me is most odd about being there well
okay so I mean first of all I don't know
if people in the audience know but Jesse
Lee Petersen is he has a program which
he films out of a I guess it's like a
Christian men's counseling center right
like he's offering he's obviously not a
therapist but the term counselor is not
regulated and he offers counseling to
men and particularly Christian men but
he also has a studio there like am I am
I saying that correctly I did not know
that I thought they were just renting
like a conventional studio I didn't know
anything about this counseling thing or
whatever yeah I think that that's why
like the name bond I think it's initials
that means I don't even know what it
means but anyway that's what he's doing
out of there
the thing that was odd to me was that
his staff they sort of seemed to be fans
of mine but it also seemed like they
were very hesitant to show that like
they were almost scared that Jesse Lee
Peterson wasn't gonna like that it was
gonna respond maybe in a way that that
was not good because when I showed up
they all immediately like they wanted
pictures and whatnot and when Jesse Lee
Peterson walked in through the room that
very quickly slowed down and all of a
sudden it was like what was this type of
thing okay what it was just a very
strange atmosphere yeah I agree
I had like similar things come up where
like a couple of them asked to take
pictures with me yeah I don't know it
was pretty strange but the way that I
kind of view it this is like my guess
and I've only been there twice but like
it feels like Jesse Lee Peterson is very
real like very much dedicated to
everything he does and it's not like a
joke or anything but the other people
that are there are just kind of along
for the ride and they're not necessarily
like as committed to whatever [ __ ]
mission wait am I let us say the effort
here I'm sorry yeah but yeah but it
seems like um the other people that are
there just kind of like along for the
ride and they're just kind of cool with
doing whatever as long as they get paid
and they kind of have fun doing it and
that's like the impression that I get
yeah I'm curious whether so after I did
it a bunch of people wrote to me and
they said hey is Jesse Lee Peterson
playing a character is he for real my
impression is he is 110 percent for real
I mean off-camera he was talking to me
about voting for Trump he was making
racist comments off-camera he was
talking about quote Mexicans and black
people and all sorts of stuff I had no
reason whatsoever to question the
authenticity of the on-air character
that he plays yeah same yeah
wouldwould uh did you get follow-up from
his audience at all um I like I I dive
into the the filth that is kind of
alright or extreme right YouTube and
everything so often that it's hard to
tell who comes from what areas in
particular because I always have so many
people that like are saying such crazy
[ __ ] all the time it feels to me based
on the call ins that Jesse Lee Peterson
got during the show and on the comments
that he gets on his YouTube that like a
lot of the people that watch him aren't
like conventional like heavy Internet
users so I don't think that a lot of
them like followed me over to like talk
[ __ ] on my youtube or on my Twitter
whatever I could be wrong but it just
seemed like I just kind of got more of
the standard same dumb comments I yeah
other people on the internet other like
right-leaning people like do you know I
don't know how low you go do you know
like the Ralph's retort or like the kill
stream or any of these types of people
no I feel like I should because people
contact me and they say David why
haven't you debunked XYZ youtuber yet
and usually it's like I just don't know
who these people are it's yeah you know
you're there you shouldn't you're not
missing anything of value but like these
people will watch like their streams and
be like oh yeah Jesse Lee Peterson
brought up a lot of really good points
are really Duncan and then those fans
will come and harass me but I don't
think Jesse Lee Peterson has the fanbase
to do that right now it doesn't seem
like it I'm I'm working on maybe doing
like an in-person thing with him with a
studio audience next time I'm in Los
Angeles and part of me is just like so
curious as to what that will be like and
then part of me is scared huh I don't
know which is which whether whether the
scared part is reasonable you said
you're doing an in-studio interview with
him I'm looking at doing an in like an a
live audience thing with them next time
I'm in LA or okay is it gonna be like
he's done organizing you know you're the
one organizing it it's unclear yeah
that's one of the car we joint
organizing it who's audience is going to
be there these are the sort of questions
that need to be answered oh okay okay I
gotcha
okay so let's start to get into some of
the some of the stuff we were going to
talk about so we last time you were on I
I think that to summarize and tell me if
I'm if the summary for where we were
last time is wrong so we can at least
start from the right place is that when
we talked about platforming we both sort
of have the perspective that there's no
like list of people that are okay or not
okay to platformer that it's all about
what we described as responsible
platforming if the ideas are more or
less worthy of being refuted and if you
feel as though you are equipped to
responsibly challenge those ideas that
that is this sort of basis on which you
evaluate whether you give somebody a
platform or not am I am I sort of like
where we were last time yeah and I think
it's more or less where I'm at I'm still
at that spot now yeah so let's pick it
up there because since there have been
like the last time we talked there are
two really two formats that have become
pretty prevalent in terms of political
debate one is these sort of like in
Internet blood sports types thing types
of things where there can be anywhere
from you know two to six people on a
stream and I've done some of them you've
done some of them you I watched one one
that you did sort of recently and I
guess the first question there is like
what's your assessment of the value of
those because I do them sometimes and
then other times I don't and basically
my decision is based solely on what kind
of an audience is it going to get not on
the sort of caliber and quality of the
discussion that's going to happen but
what's your sense of that format which
now I guess it's profitable for some
people I don't know they I'm guessing
they wouldn't do it if it wasn't wait
wait can we hold on wait one second I
think your stream cut out for a second I
don't you to miss too much in your my
stream cut out or yeah your stream on is
having internet problems right now huh
that's weird
seems to be working fine over here but
that's strange does here is your I don't
know if you can see the OBS on your
computer is it like red in the bottom
right does it look like it's not like
transmitting enough internet or no no
it's all green oh wait hold on wait
people are some people are saying it's
okay no okay now run all right I'm just
I've got your chat open and I saw how
much people when people put apps in the
chat that usually means there's a lot of
internet problems no see I wouldn't even
know that I appreciate that
it's fine okay I'm sorry so you were
your question was basically asking is
there any value of these internet blood
sports six people yell at each other and
it's goes on for one two three four
hours sometimes like do we gain anything
from that so okay so there's like a
million ways to talk about this so I'll
try to be as succinct as possible I
think that there are a lot of people
that admire people that are willing to
go like into the trenches and like
viciously defend what they believe
against other people and I think that
there are people that believe that that
this has a merit in and of itself and I
think that I am somebody that because of
what I do I think I'm kind of in a
unique spot to gather viewers or
followers because I'm willing to engage
in that so to be clear I'm not saying
everybody should be willing to or that
everybody needs to or this something
that everybody should practice to do but
if you can do it I do think there's a
value there because I do think that
people now I'm not saying that it's
right or wrong or good or bad that
people do this but people look up to
people that are capable of entering an
arena with a ton of people that
viciously disagree with you
and then being able to have like this
sort of like bro ish alpha-male whatever
like back and forth conversation with
these types of people and I do think
it's guarded me a lot of respect and in
certain areas of the internet that has
let people listen to my content that
wouldn't be the type of people that
would like open a contra points video
and watch for more than two seconds
because they're scared of like a trans
person you know is there I mean is
changing minds it should changing minds
even be a priority during those things
or like is that just not because not
what it's about at all
I mean I usually the thing that I say is
the 40-40-20 thing we're like they're
gonna be people on both sides that are
so dug in I can be as dumb as I want the
other person could be as dumb as they
want and no one will change their minds
but there are people in the middle that
are kind of undecided and these are
usually the people that I look for like
if I feel like I go on to somebody
else's stream who's crazy and I feel
like I have a really good showing the
top voted comments are all gonna be
[ __ ] on me but if you go down a
little bit you'll start to find like
upvoted comments and they're like hey
like normally I'm a big fan of your
stream but I don't think this was your
best showing or I'll trick like reddit
threads or subreddit threads about a lot
of these things in people like hey you
know I feel like you know especially for
Digg Masterson I feel like dick is a
really smart guy bla bla bla but this
was a really bad showing for him I don't
think he did well and usually those are
the types of people that I'm kind of
like looking to move over just kind of
like showing like hey this person isn't
as infallible as you think they are is
the format so I'm sure as you know some
of these things like they're literally
for hours dreams words it just goes on
and on and on or six all right yeah or
six I mean yeah at six hour I don't even
I don't even watch on 2x speed but so
there's this common feedback that I get
from people because sometimes I'll be
invited onto these things and people
will write in and I'll say David you
know it's like I get the point of
engaging with people who disagree and
the topic is sort of interesting but
when something is for hours like there's
no way to sort of succinctly take
anything away from it
just I remember what I remember is
people talk for a long time some people
talk louder than others some people talk
more quickly than others but like
ultimately my takeaways are just that
the conversation took place and that's
where I wonder like is it even is that
even a format where you know we talked
about on cable news you get four minutes
to talk about something I'm like
obviously that's a ridiculous format to
talk in depth about anything but on the
other hand is three two three four or
five hours on a single topic that is is
that a format that also really
communicates information of value to the
audience I just don't know I mean it has
an audience right there are people that
watch it and the
that I view a lot of this stuff is at
the end of the day like there are people
that are gonna tune in to these types of
things if I can present like a
left-leaning perspective or I should say
like a progressive perspective
perspective a progressive perspective on
these types of shows and I and I think
I'm equipped well to do it then yeah for
sure I would love to be involved in that
because otherwise these things just end
up being screaming matches between a
bunch of alt writers and everybody kind
of like laughs about it and you know
they have all their memes and everything
but you don't really get like a
progressive point of view ever presented
in an effective manner so I mean like
there's a special type of viewer that
watches these long-term things like
these aren't the types of people I mean
you even know this right so it's all
like for instance like the types of the
type of person that watches like a
YouTube video isn't the same type of
person to watch a live stream so like
you can have people with a lot of
YouTube subs that don't really get quite
as many viewers on on live streams and
you're gonna people with a lot of live
stream viewers that don't get quite as
many YouTube viewers just because it's
like a different type of audience so I
do think there is an audience that
watches this long-form content and
consumes it a lot differently than
people that conventionally watch YouTube
videos so let me bring up now in these
sort of trends of platforms and formats
that we've been seeing and everybody
listen everybody's gonna know that I'm
talking about dave rubin so i'll just
say like he sort of RiRi he's on the
vanguard of this format once again and
it's this what does a standing up
straight without a backbone er you know
we that may be part of it but what I'm
actually talking about is this idea of I
want to get ideas out into the ether I'm
not here to fight people on every
assertion it doesn't mean I agree with
everything that they're saying but I'm
all about ideas and hearing about the
ideas that people have and what this has
led to in practice is pretty fair
criticisms of Ruben for allowing quite
frankly unhinged right-wingers to say
things that are ridiculous that that are
just they're just wrong and and they're
demonstrably wrong but by any standard
of examination but the the argument is
that the format is one where people just
get to sort of give their perspective
and Dave wants to learn about their
ideas if I did that with Richard Spencer
like when I interviewed Richard Spencer
if I took that approach my audience
would not tolerate it and I'm sort of
interested in your perspective on is
that a legitimate perspective to take or
is it is it just something that you've
got to find a niche audience that's okay
with that but it's
not something that we learn much from I
think it's totally legitimate to want to
have all ideas expressed out there but
it already happens they're called
[ __ ] libraries or you can go on
Wikipedia and you can read about them
this idea that you you are you want all
ideas to be here so you bring them on to
a [ __ ] internet radio show or
whatever is absolute [ __ ] you're not
you're not just you're not just like
platforming the ideas you're working as
their publicist or PR firm at that point
you know if I bring on some guy to talk
about like history revisionism who's a
neo-nazi that at the end of the day the
consequence of that is there are going
to be some people that listen to and go
oh you know this guy actually made a lot
of really good points you know I think
I'm gonna go and research more about
this and some of those people will
inevitably be lost down that hole of
kind of like alright propaganda and this
can be true of any idea of platforming
you know either like science deniers
climate change deniers you know people
that are extremely conservative people
that are extremely you know religious
now that these all ideas are all like
equally bad or equally good or whatever
but just like when you platform an idea
and you don't challenge it then
inevitably some percentage of your fan
base is going to look into that idea
more and then kind of be lost to it
whether that's a good thing or a bad
thing so I mean like I would argue that
we have a responsibility as public
figures to platform things that we that
kind of like a line with our moral
values you know I have a set of morals
that I believe in in terms of um you
know what what should people do in
society what people ought to do in
society and if I were to bring on like
not see after not see after not see
after like traditional conservatives
traditional conservatives like now that
these are the same I keeps trying to say
that because I don't think like all
conservatives are not so every but like
basically people that I heavily disagree
with politically or morally all I'm
doing is I'm exposing my fan base to
their idea so that they can you know
eventually kind of like flow over to
that part of the internet and then be a
part of that group why would I do that
it doesn't make any sense as stupid yeah
Dave Rubin is is basically a prop for
kind of like conservatives to spread
their message that's all he is he's not
platforming ideas he's like he's like a
stage one recruitment platform for a lot
of these conservatives online that's
what he does why do you know he's doing
it why do you think this is the format
he's decided on because you could take
the position that I mean listen it's not
for us to figure out the exact of
financial logistics of the show but the
case has been made that it's because
he's not equipped to actually refute the
ideas the case has been made that it's
because he agrees with the ideas the
cases were made that it's because of the
people who fund his show and they're
just funneling him these guests and
implying go
easy on them do you have any strong
opinion on that so I like to I think
there's something called Hanlon's razor
or Hamlin's razor and it's basically
it's never attribute to malice that
which is adequately explained by
stupidity I don't like to assume that a
person is an evil actor unless I have
really good reason to think so
I honestly think Dave Rubin like so many
other useful idiots online it's just
really really [ __ ] stupid he doesn't
deserve to be in this space he's not
equipped for it he's he's just he's
completely uninformed he doesn't have
the intellectual rigor to take on any of
these ideas I don't even mean that in a
big way I use me like he's real dumb
he's real real real dumb and yeah I
think he just ends up being like kind of
like a useful idiot like a puppet for a
lot of those more kind of insidious
conservative groups that are trying to
spread their influence online and I
think that's kind of yeah I think that's
where Dave Rubin sits at right now
that's what it feels like to me I feel
like there is and I'm curious what you
think there are elements on the left and
the right that for me sometimes get a
little bit too much in the direction of
suppressing reasonable conversations and
by reasonable I don't mean conversations
with reasonable people but I mean
conversations where bad ideas are
actually going to be challenged in a
serious way and and the example that I
have been thinking about for a while is
when I interviewed Richard Spencer like
a year and a half ago or something like
that you know I knew what his ideas were
I find his ideas disgusting and
deplorable he knew that there was no
sort of pretense that this was let's
figure out what white national let's
think we sort of know what they think
and we're going to challenge these ideas
and after the interview obviously there
were people on the right who didn't like
it but there were people on the Left who
wrote to me who said this is just a
really bad idea to even give someone
like Richard Spencer airtime and I went
back and I did a youtube search Richard
Spencer interview and like within two
weeks of when I talked to him Artie had
interviewed him CNN had interviewed him
and they were relatively milquetoast
interviews where his ideas were not
seriously challenged and to me it's like
is the problem that he's getting airtime
or is the problem that he's getting
airtime on corporate media or media
where he's not being challenged and I
feel like the left you know the right I
don't even try to argue with the right
on this but I feel like the left needs
to not make this mistake I 100 million
percent agree
we did it for a long time in the United
States especially like kind of seen what
happened with Trump where like the air
time with Trump was basically like lol
like it out dummy is like oh my god
Trump is so dumb right and everybody
like let you know liberal outlets just
kind of like aired it over and over
again like oh my God look at this dumb
thing that Trump said and in the
election rolled around is like oh [ __ ]
like I guess these people don't all
think Trump is really dumb like oh [ __ ]
maybe we should have actually addressed
some of the things that he said because
they are worth addressing you know um I
mean like you kind of see this like
boiled down into Hillary's uh you know
Trampas like make America great again
and Hillary's like America is already
great it's like okay well not everybody
feels that way and at some point you're
gonna have to address that whether you
want to or not like you you have to
address some of these issues because
people on the right are doing it and
people on the Left aren't you know like
today in the progressive movement we
push a lot of minority figures you know
black people women and whatnot to the
front of media it's just to feel like
they have voices and representation
which is great and I think we should
absolutely do that and I love that we're
seeing that more but for some reason
we've kind of got this idea where we
leave a lot of white people feeling
vilified now I'm not gonna sit here and
make the ludicrous argument that like
the white man is the most persecuted
blah blah blah any stupid [ __ ] like that
right however there are a lot of people
that feel that way and when you look at
the left well okay well let's say I'm
kind of like a I want to be like a woke
white dude like who do I look at on the
left you know and you don't really have
very many people to look to and then you
go to the right and you have these
incredibly persuasive rhetoricians the
people like Jordan Peterson then it's
like oh well [ __ ] like there's only one
place to go you know Jordan Peterson is
giving me like a lot of advice he's
giving me like reasonable ways to view
my life because a lot of his self up
stuff is actually good whether or not
lefties want to admit it and then
there's none of that on the left and
it's like well [ __ ] it you're losing the
rhetoric battle and at the end of the
day that's really all that matters you
can be as right as you want but if
you're not persuasive nobody's gonna
care what you have to say are you
familiar with this Christian financial
dude Dave Ramsey no what does he do okay
I've heard that name before
well here's the thing I mean the reason
I bring him up is I think that there is
a significant similarity between
Christian financial dude dave ramsey and
jordan peterson and it's this similarity
the things jordan peterson is saying
that are as you say sort of like
reasonable sensible advice for most
people if applied responsibly are not
unique or new to jordan Peterson Jordan
Peterson didn't come up with them he
sort of repackaged
in a way that comes along with a whole
bunch of other stuff that is problematic
Dave Ramsey 75 to 80% of his financial
advice is uncontroversial it's been
around for like a hundred years if you
go back and read you know 1920s basic
financial advice but he repackages it
along with this sort of born-again
evangelical stuff and connects it in
that way and what happens with Peterson
is a lot of the people that fall for
Peterson they see the sensible stuff and
then they believe that his worldview is
like an extra group inextricably tied in
to that simple basic advice yes and so
then they fall for the worldview
similarly out Dave Ramsey you see people
he's like listen you got to pay off the
debt that has the highest interest rate
first if you don't have six months of
expenses saved that's an emergency and
you've got to deal with that and by the
way when you pay off your debt you do
this primal scream that's similar to
like when a Christian person is born
again and it gets all tied in and that's
why these guys are so dangerous because
they're sort of articulate nature and
and a presentation wraps together the
uncontroversial stuff with the worldview
yeah and anybody that like anybody that
tells a lot of lies knows that this is
like true as well like if you want to
tell a really good lie you always have
to ground it out in something that's
true you always have to start with
something that the other person knows is
true because then when you go in to tell
the lie if they know that part of what
you said is true it because really hard
to separate like the fact from the
fiction later on you know and people
people do this thing where they get
outside of they kind of get outside of
what they know for a variety of reasons
this is one of my big criticisms
actually like Jordan Peterson right
where I think that Jordan Peterson is
qualified to talk about self-help stuff
I really do because when I live because
when I watch videos people and people do
this long time they link videos like
look at this stupid Jordan Peterson
video by the sing and I'll click it and
it's like a self happening I'm actually
thinking like this is actually pretty
good there's actually really on point
like I actually really agree with this
but then people like Jordan Peterson I
guess because they get really good in
one area I think like oh well you know
since I could do this I'm gonna go and
talk about like philosophy or history or
politics I was like oh god stop but all
the people that followed him along for
the first thing because I thought it was
like oh well if he knew that he must
know literally every single other topic
right and people do this with Elon Musk
people do this with Neil deGrasse Tyson
people do this with with with all sorts
of people there the Bill Nye the Science
Guy right like yeah
it's a really bad thing but it happens
yeah the big con for me with Peterson is
not that he has repackaged basic advice
that's been around for a long time and
is profiting from it it's it's actually
that there are people who sort of fall
for the sort of more grandiose theories
that he presents about the real problem
in modern society is this neo-marxist
postmodern egalitarian obsession that
the far left has become an entangled wid
that they can't seem to get away from or
whatever else and that for me is like
really the the big con that he's waged
and has convinced people with because
it's much it's much easier just to take
like the piece of self-help advice and
say oh yeah that applies to me or that
doesn't apply to me and it's like much
more clear-cut whether it's something
that that is relevant for you but then
when you see that that stuff is
charismatic as you point out and you say
hey you know maybe maybe the problem is
these radical leftists at universities
and the suppression of speech or
whatever it's way harder to Reason
yourself out of that stuff when you're
in it yeah and like people on the left
always well I know it's not people all
everybody does this people always want
to see people is holy good or holy bad
and it's just not true and I try to
stress this all the time like I never
make the or I try not to make like to
clean your room jokes about like Jordan
Peterson because that advice and
everything he talks about there's
actually really good and one of the
problems that you run into is it when
people on the other side start falling
for some of this but some of that
rhetoric and then you won the love so
there and say well everything about that
is untrue what's like well hold on this
is your basically do you know what dare
is it's like the drug enforce abuse
resistance education yeah yeah like it's
probably not a good idea to smoke
marijuana every single [ __ ] day
that's probably really bad but if you're
telling me that if I smoke marijuana my
dick is gonna shrivel up and fall off
I'm probably not gonna listen to
anything that you have to say you know
like you can actually say things like
hey Jordan Peterson offers a lot of good
self health advice but as politics are
really bad there's nothing wrong with
that statement and people on the left
always feel like they have to brush off
oh no I'm sorry people on both sides but
we're talking about a left or not right
will always brush off every single thing
that somebody has to say like there's no
valid criticism in there whatsoever you
know like I'm not I'm not a Marxist but
I think that there are valid criticisms
that Marx levies against capitalism I
don't believe in the red pill
at all but there are a lot of really
valid things that read pillows bring up
that you have to be prepared to address
and this writing off an entire ideology
wholesale is only gonna drive people
away that do see the nuggets of truth
that those ideologies are offering do
you what do you see is the shelf life of
Peterson because this could be a guy who
until he is in his 80s is in demand as a
speaker and continues writing these
books that are that are bestsellers in
30-40 languages or whatever or maybe he
just sort of like evaporates in five
years and I don't know which way it's
gonna go I mean it all depends on if he
has like social issues that he can kind
of like hinge himself on I guess like
cuz when you look at a lot of people
like to pretend that Jordan Peterson got
famous for doing self-help stuff but if
you if you go back and you look like his
YouTube analytics for instance yeah you
see a massive uptick when that c16 stuff
happened like that's when he first
started to really get popular you know
so as long as there are these issues
that he can kind of like hook himself on
to and to kind of like remain relevant
to talk about he'll probably continue to
be popular that would be my guess but I
mean it's hard for me to predict exactly
what will happen you know like nobody
could have predicted like Milo's
downfall would have been as Extreme as
it was to go from literally being on
like you know Showtime with Bill Maher
and stuff and then to like having the
the pedophile stuff come out and now
he's like he can't like fill an audience
on like an auditorium and yeah just
another speaking tour I guess just got
cancelled again or something I got read
I pay very little attention to that but
I did see that that article okay so
let's get into the ad boycott stuff now
which is I feel like from our last
conversation this was the most serious
disagreement we had which was that I
think in short I sort of defended
lobbying advertisers to pull advertising
from shows as a kind of legitimate
method of political activism and I think
generally speaking what you you didn't
say that it should be illegal or
anything like that but you were just
against it as a pragmatic point of view
um
I guess like I'm in favor of it but for
only the reasons I agree with and not
for the yeah so I mean it's kind of one
of those things it's kind of like guys
like do you think you should be allowed
to kill people it's like well if I think
it's justified right you should like in
self-defense or whatever and somebody
else might agree as well but they might
say for like well apostasy or something
you know like that and it's like well I
don't agree that so like yeah I mean
like I guess it's more kind of like the
more fundamental questions like who
should have ads pulled from them because
like for instance
and unless you think about like an
extreme free speech person an extreme
free speech advocate I don't think
anybody should say like oh well if you
want to come on and literally do an
entire show dedicated to the supremacy
of white people you have a right to have
like advertiser sponsor program unless
would you take that position I'm not
trying to like get you well I mean I
don't know that it's a here's the thing
I don't know that it's a question of
rights for me this is the fundamental
issue I'm when it comes to if we're
talking about the speech of those who
are hosting the show
versus advertising decisions are also a
form of speech and anything that the
advertiser wants to take into
consideration when deciding where they
want to advertise they're obviously free
to do and then the speech of the
activists who wants to contact MetLife
or whatever company and Lobby them to
make a decision one way or the other on
the basis that they would boycott that
company if that company keeps
advertising somewhere I don't want to
restrict anybody's speech presuming that
it's not against the law so that that's
like my starting point so I feel like
any activism that I do against ad
boycott demands other than saying I
don't think they're effective or I'll
get to what some of my problems are with
them I don't want to kind of get get
ahead of myself anything that is sort of
at top of a top level saying this is a
type of speech that I don't think people
should exercise I I hesitate to make
that argument okay um I guess so this is
something I would have agreed with a
while ago but my position on kind of
like deep platforming has evolved quite
a bit okay over the past like
year-and-a-half I hate bad faith actors
or people that engage with gross
negligence in public discourse and I
think all of these people should be
aggressively removed from any type of
public platform I don't think they serve
any good whatsoever okay I think all
they do is dilute the conversations and
cause people to get by I think that
these people are actually they represent
a fundamental attack against some of our
fundamental structures that make
democracy work but with an example of
one of these just so everybody knows
like the type of thing you're talking
about sure so when you engage in either
totally factually incorrect information
or grossly negligent of information so
here's like we can do a ton of exams but
like here's what like a very easy one do
you know who Sargon of Akkad is right
I'm assuming or no yes I know him as
Carl Benjamin Carl Benjamin okay you
call him car inside of Sargon
so like Carl does this thing a lot where
he brings up studies or he makes like
these comments about people or things or
places that have happened but these
things either don't happen the way that
he says they do or he's just completely
and totally wrong look one of the
clearest examples I can think of is um
there is a a journalist lady that wrote
an article about council housing have
you heard of this no yeah but basically
he said something along the lines of
like of course this council of course
this journalist comes out in favor of
council housing she's never seen one
before and then like you know and people
I think Sean and Jen did a YouTube video
this is like well actually you know
she's literally lived in them and if you
would have just clicked the Twitter
profile on her thing you would have seen
that she's lived in them before and then
Carl came out made another Ben he's like
oh well she probably never lived in any
of the bad ones like any of the ones in
some place and like Sean and Jen was
like well actually this is almost
exactly like where she said she's been
at or something like that and it was
like really bad it was really obvious
that Carl was like totally wrong on
everything he was saying and these
people that like make these statements
that are just factually incorrect like
we can't have conversations our
democracy dies if we literally can't
have conversations that are rooted in
like fact-based conversations or or like
trump when Trump like just blatantly
lies about something you know when he
says things like three million people
illegally voted in the last election so
I sure wait what the [ __ ] are you
talking about like this isn't even like
like a disagreement you're just like
this is just factually not true okay but
for the purposes of our conversation so
okay Carl Benjamin just has bad faith
argument or totally ignorant argument
where he repeatedly asserts things that
aren't true okay yeah how does that how
does that relate so how you say he
should doesn't even deserve to have a
platform how should his platform be
removed um I mean like I think people
should actively try to boycott it or
private companies should like have like
rules against like these sorts of like
bad faith actors where they're just like
oh we're not gonna host you if you
literally just serve to spread
misinformation here okay but hold on
because now now I'm trying to follow
that so uh-huh
you could have terms of service
obviously but producing content in bad
faith is one that I you know I I don't
call something a slippery slope unless I
actually think there is one I think
we've got to be careful that's a pretty
slippery slope to say we you you can't
do Gore crimes or bad faith arguments I
just don't know from a practical
perspective how you enforce something
like that
yeah and this is kind of like I don't
want to say that this is like so there's
something called the Nirvana fallacy so
let's say for instance like we're on a
boat we're in a ship that's sinking into
the ocean and and I'm like hey we should
jump on one of the lifeboats and sail
away be like well hold on right we don't
know this lifeboat is gonna hold us we
don't know what the capacity is it could
have a hole in it we haven't checked and
it's like okay well hold on like the
ship that we're sinking on right now is
[ __ ] sinking like this is not working
we can nitpick every single like
alternative that I give but the reality
is is that what we're on right now is
absolutely failing like you can't tell
me that unless I present you a perfect a
perfect alternative that we can't even
consider it you know and I'm not saying
you're doing that exactly but like a lot
of people when I bring up my stance on
deep platforming they'll say like hey
well couldn't this be a slippery slope
couldn't there be problems of
implementing this how do we know that
this is working and yeah for sure a lot
of this would be really difficult to
implement but in my opinion the reality
is is that right now our inability to
have fact-based conversations is
literally destroying our democracy like
I don't think we can continue on like
this for very much longer if we
literally are believing in things like
[ __ ] - and nun or or like pizza gate
I don't think that we can actually have
an established working democracy because
like being able to get information
that's true though there's like one of
our like fundamental institutions we
have to be able to do this so I think
it's worth shaking things I mean try it
I don't disagree with the concerns that
you're outlining but to step back for a
second from the the good faith thing you
you mentioned two things that should
happen with this to it - Karl Benjamin
you said you talked about the platforms
to decide you can't you can't do this
bad face-to-face stuff on our platform
but then you actually said that there
should be a boycott of sargon of akkad
which from our last conversation I
thought you had said that you were
against advertiser boycotts do you mean
people should just boycott his channel
as viewers rather than going after
advertisers um well I would have to
remember exactly I don't like the idea
where it depends on the the subject
material being boycotted so for instance
like I don't believe I just hate bad
faith actors I'm not as concerned with
like hate speech even though that can
lead to bad outcomes but like if
somebody wants to get online and do like
a KKK channel or like a whatever [ __ ]
like that I don't think that they should
necessarily be boycotted or ads should
be pulled or whatever blah blah blah I
just want to get rid of the bad faith
the bad faith actors like if somebody
wants to get online and make like a
Richard
Showtek wants to talk about like how
white people are superior black people
that's fine we can have that
conversation you can have a channel or
whatever like I am hot like 30 seconds
of a stream of his did like he actually
has that he has the Richard Spencer show
now and that's what he does and what is
it monetized I would guess it's not but
but I don't you know again if he knows
how to toe the line between actually
advocating violence and not and I think
we just need to make sure as as the
anti-authoritarian free speech left that
I consider myself a member of I want to
make sure that if I am actually telling
a private company that I want them to
restrict the speech of someone that that
same rule applied across the board is
not going to have unintended
consequences yeah yeah I agree you just
subscribe a real utilitarianism which is
exactly what I am but so I 100% agree
that we shouldn't like craft a rule that
could basically be utilized in a way in
the future that we wouldn't want it to
be but I mean like I hope to never be a
bad faith actor like I try my best to do
my research if I'm talking to somebody
that seems way more informed on a topic
than I am I usually like you know I let
them talk I'm not gonna sit here like
make stuff up or try to lie to get a
point across so I mean I would hope that
like any rule that I craft that says
like a bad faith actor or somebody that
engages in gross negligence and doesn't
do anything to like prevent this you
know I don't think I would ever fall
under that I would hope not to to follow
a rule that would like cut me down there
you know so to expand on my position
from last time we talked because again
we just like we figured out that we
apparently had a disagreement on this in
like the last five minutes that we were
talking what one of my principles is any
restriction on boycotts of any kind and
this implies not only boycotting
advertisers but boycotting the program
any restrictions on on those boy
boycotts I see as restrictions on speech
and so I'm against them sort of on on
principle but that's a different thing
than saying that boycotts may or may not
be a good strategy and one of the things
that concerns me about advertiser
boycotts is that this is our the best
argument that I've come across in trying
to steal man an anti advertiser boycott
position do we really want advertisers
having more power to decide what topics
are covered and how they're covered in
media because if you go after an
advertiser for advertising on a program
that has a
position on any issue pick the issue
right abortion gay marriage education
whatever as soon as the advertiser
starts getting involved in the minutiae
of we're gonna pull our money because
the host took this point of view or
whatever the advertiser effectively gets
even more power and and I think that
huge corporations already have a ton of
power so that's my like the best
argument for me against ad boycotts is
that it puts editorial control into the
hands of advertisers and that's a real
problem um you're killing me
I'm a big capitalist okay let me preface
that I hate lefties okay but I what
you're talking about is basically just
you're just critiquing capitalism of
this point like you're saying like do we
want advertisers goddamnit I hate making
all these left the arguments cuz no my
but basically what you're saying already
happens right advertisers already decide
whose platform like that so the major
media yeah the major media organizations
are already controlled by massive
conglomerates outcome elections are
already decided by wealthy people and
lobbyists you know large companies
already decided like what type of like
speech we see and what gets platform to
whatever like it already happened so I
mean it seems like people pressuring
advertisers is at least in some way
taking the decision from the advertisers
and giving it back to the people in some
ways right you know you vote with your
wallet like but that's now that's the
argument I was making last time which
you were disagreeing with it sounds like
you have had sort of a to not not to
make you the next Dave Rubin but it
sounds like you've had a political
awakening on this issue of sorts it I
don't I don't remember how long ago we
talked last time but well it was years
well what cuz no cuz I've actually won a
teat on this position completely involve
if you would if you would have talked to
me and I know two years ago I am I was
an extreme anti D platformer like I
thought every speech should be hosted
everything should be online no boycott
should have been all of asserted that
was my position I want 80 100 percent on
this position so that so it's possible
that if you talk me back then that my
position right now is quite different
yeah I absolutely think that bad faith
actors should be eradicated from the
internet and with no violent connotation
or that like they just they just don't
they don't serve the public discourse in
any way size shape or form it's just so
horrible like it they just do nothing
good for us one of the one of the
strongest arguments that I see in
supporting
advertise or boycotts and in a second
I'm gonna talk about people who say but
David you could be hurt by this and what
about what happens as soon as people
start boycotting you and I'll talk about
that in a second in our society this is
kind of like a critique of capitalism
and again I I'm a social democrat right
I'm not a democratic socialist or a
Stalinist
or a communist or anything I want
regulated capitalism individuals have
very little power to fight back against
the sort of combined power of big media
corporations in the political system
yeah boycotts can potentially be a tool
to do that the average person has very
little say over whether Tucker Carlson
keeps his show on Fox News the average
person has very little say over the
regulatory environment that allowed Fox
News and CNN and MSNBC to get so big and
the media consolidation that has taken
place the advertiser boycott is a
slightly indirect way of actually at
least attempting to get back some of the
power that individuals have lost over
the last 4050 years relative to huge
corporations and media conglomerates and
for me that's like the strongest reason
to be completely in favor of advertiser
boycotts sure a little bit yeah I kind
of I'm I don't like in a way this kind
of segues into a totally different
conversation because for instance let's
say that all of our media was like not
necessarily state-run but state-funded
our positions on this might be a lot
different right if like if all of media
wasn't for-profit like entertainment
driven you know like like metric driven
you know what gives us the most viewers
what's the most entertaining [ __ ] we
might have different positions on this
so it's hard to have those two
conversations separately does that make
sense yeah I do understand what you're
saying but you know the I think that
when you consider I mean listen like
like let's take a step back for a second
if we were just to say what are the ways
in which an individual can most
effectively exercise their desires in
American society right we can say well
okay you go and you vote and then you
realize well you can vote but the
legislative desires of corporations and
of rich people are way more likely to
actually be made into into the law than
those of just middle class Joe or
whatever there's an interesting
Princeton study on on the
that demonstrates this so then it's like
well maybe voting is actually not really
the equalizer that some might might hope
it to be so my point is when the rubber
meets the road what are the most
effective ways for the individual to
impact the society in which they live
revolution is what all the lefties would
say I mean don't ask me this question I
don't know it is I mean it's interesting
because you could disagree with my
framing but instead of disagreeing with
my frame and you're sort of saying man
I'm kind of like where my mind is going
is the the so-called radical left
perspective I mean III don't disagree
your friend me at all I mean I 100 agree
I mean like the federal government has
enough information to file a taxes for
us if you're a simple w-2 owner if you
if you just earned w2 income that the
federal government can do it yes there's
no reason why they can sure but we there
are riders on legislation that
Republicans have passed because they get
Lobby buy into it to make it so that we
the federal government the IRS is not
allowed to actually do that it's against
the law for them to automatically follow
your tax form I don't remember voting
for that building
anybody motive for that I'd only anybody
would vote for that so there's a lot of
stuff that gets kind of like passed
through legislatively that we don't
directly have our hands on which is in a
way the consequence of representative
democracy I understand but the problem
isn't so much that we're not being
represented or the problem isn't or
rather the problem isn't we're not
directly voting at every single piece of
legislation the problem is who are the
constituents of the people in Congress
and I mean kind of what we're getting
and it doesn't feel like your
constituents are the people in your
districts it kind of feels like it's the
people that are giving you money to win
your elections which is not oftentimes
like the average person that's being
represented you know yeah yeah I mean
we're sort of getting - I mean it's like
this is just such a broader thing but as
we've been talking about on my program
for a while when you talk about
representative democracy the idea would
be that you know a member of Congress
that represents it's like seven hundred
and something thousand people that are
in their third congressional district
that their votes would reflect not what
other elected officials in Washington
say is going to be our platform I mean
really they would represent the views of
the seven hundred and something thousand
people that that put them there but we
simply know that that's not the case and
that that that's a much bigger issue
that we have to deal with it's not
really a representative democracy it's a
democracy
that is representative of moneyed
corporate and wealthy interests and I
don't I can't imagine you and I would
disagree about that I I don't know if
anybody could disagree with that right
yeah I guess the question is whether
we're better off with that system versus
you know I mean when you go back when
you go back to Socrates Socrates was not
like the biggest fan of totally
representative democracy sort of for the
the similar reasons that we're kind of
alluding to here which is the masses
don't necessarily make the best
decisions but this is kind of like a
broader I mean I don't even know if that
we want to go down this path necessarily
I mean I like representative democracy
for a few reasons actually I think
represented democracy is way better than
direct democracy
you can't expect every citizen to be
totally updated on every piece of
legislation it's just not realistic from
you run into issues where sometimes it's
better for political processes to move a
little bit more slowly for instance
could you imagine leaving the future of
your country and its place maybe in like
a large trading body up to the average
citizen to vote on that could end
catastrophically maybe absolutely so
things like Bragg's if for instance it's
not like I I'm okay with the idea of a
representative democracy I just think
the problem is like the representative
democracy isn't representing the
constituents and the actual districts
the people it's representing the people
that pay the money to win their
elections and some sort of election
reform there is probably like really
important to make it so that that
doesn't happen
so you mentioned revolution and we don't
have to talk about revolution but let's
actually talk about some so we talked
before on my program about sort of like
okay and you can sign petitions online
and those probably do nothing other than
maybe raising some awareness about
what's our getting like a funny response
from somebody on the White House's own
hands yeah
you can go and vote and of course voting
creates change in an indirect way that's
also relatively slow so like if you look
at what are some other neat sort of
violent revolution what are some other
protest methods that activists can do
and you often hear civil disobedience
strategic loan defaults everybody stops
paying their mortgages it completely
shuts down you know the financial system
in a way that that Congress has to
intervene and and maybe you get
something out of that we deal with that
really interesting I haven't heard that
idea
before maybe everybody defaults on a
student loan or something yeah the idea
of that is that if enough people act
together you can shut down the financial
system on which all of these industries
and government rely and that is a way to
maybe get get people's attention but
what what I want to get to is we
obviously can imagine how that would
work at scale but you know a million
people signed up saying if X happens
we're gonna rally if Trump tries to fire
Moeller or whatever I mean the Moller
report told us that Trump did try to
fire Moeller and Don Magan said I'm not
gonna do it nobody's rallying right I
mean people are busy you you can't
you're not even sure half the country
can't meet an unexpected 400 dollar
expense so so what is it actually gonna
take to get people to go and do mass
rallies and stop working I don't know
what the answer is well as far as like
stuff like that this is my position on
this as always and this is totally I'm
sure like a sociology somebody could
have a well more nuanced position but my
opinion all of this is like until people
are actually like starving or like
facing the threat of not having a basic
need met so we could look at that like
whatever Maslow's hierarchy of needs of
like your fundamental like if you don't
have shelter food or clothing yeah
that's when that's what actually gets
people out into the streets to start
like rioting and [ __ ] I don't think it's
gonna be like you know president Trump
tweets out the four hundred the
ridiculous dumb [ __ ] thing or fires like
the next like FBI directory something I
don't think that's actually gonna get
people out in the streets like in mass
like riding and I don't think that's
gonna happen yeah and this is why I
think still that the most likely
scenario is Trump just kind of gets
reelected with with relatively little
controversy in 2020 and I don't know
where you are on that I don't whether or
not Trump gets really I would have to
check out isn't he not doing as well
like in the popularity polls like even
them all the report stuff didn't like
vindicate him as much as he wished it
would I don't here's the thing he's got
like a high 30s approval rating and a
new poll says 55% of the country won't
vote for him but you can easily win with
those numbers because half the country
doesn't vote and we have an electoral
college system well I mean I'm hoping
that the people doing those polls are
projecting these to like voting
populations right yeah whether or not
Trump gets reelected I think is largely
going to depend on how how the Democrat
stuff pans out I have like intentionally
not followed much because there are like
50 people like looking for book deals
right now that are all running as
Democrats so when we get a little bit
closer
the debate session will start like
tearing into the candidates more I heard
that Biden is running I don't know how I
I hope like is a little bit more
cognizant of their progressive base and
of like the very Moberly active people
actively mobile people that like want to
get out and protest and be excited kind
of like Bernie's audience was kind of
like Trump's audience was and I hope I
don't know man I really shouldn't say
anything is it responsible because I
haven't looked in as much but the idea
of like Biden being like the Democratic
frontrunner is very [ __ ] scary to me
and it feels very much like a repeat of
what we just did with Hillary on the
political spectrum they're similar
Biden's significantly older he's also
male I mean I've said if some people
have been writing to me angrily saying
I'm I'm Pro Biden I'm not pro Biden I'm
pointing out that he's been doing well
in the polls since before he was running
and he raised a bunch of money on his
first day and I think he's generally a
good debater but I think it's it's a bad
idea to go to Hillary what is
effectively Hillary Clinton 2.0 is there
is there anybody else that and if you
just don't if you're not following it
that's totally fine is there anybody
else you particularly don't like who's
running um but I particularly don't like
um for not for good reasons no no I I'm
still kind of like I'm in the Bernie
camp right now I think although Bernie
Bernie fans are fanatic holy [ __ ]
although maybe that's a good thing I
mean Trump fans were fanatic keep it
Bernie fans are crazy but I still
generally like Bernie even though he has
a lot of positions that I think are
really stupid or a couple that I think
are really dumb I think for the most
part he's like anti-nuclear power oh
yeah I don't like that he seems to be
like very protectionist which i think is
very naive so for instance he's not a
big fan of things like NAFTA or the TPP
and I think there are problems there I
don't think that isolationist
overprotective thing looks works very
well like in this you know day and age
but for the most part I like Bernie I
like a lot of his like domestic policies
and the way that he would like you know
kind of be more social in terms of like
redistributing wealth what I think are
good for him I feel like the problem
problem with a lot of the way people
talk about trade policy is that it sort
of assumes we're going back to the
beginning before we have sort of like
geopolitics and and you know
globalization so you'll hear arguments
that are
sort of like flatly here's why in
rational actor classical economics if
you're starting from zero tariffs are
bad or tariffs are good or protectionism
or whatever and I feel like what's
lacking from all of these arguments is
that these principles don't account for
the fact that we've got like several
hundred years of relationships and
economic policy and decisions that we
are starting from and you're not
starting in a vacuum and therefore you
sort of have to account for not what
happens in an economics textbook when
you apply certain policy but what is the
effect also considering geopolitical
relationships and like what I think this
applies to both Trump and Bernie that a
lot of their analyses on trade miss that
context yeah it's very populist
like it's very like for the people
driven you know it's very easy for
everybody to rally behind you know and
[ __ ] on the TPP like oh it's so bad it
gives all these protections to blah blah
blah and it's like yeah there were
definitely problems with it but if
America just says well [ __ ] this I'm out
I mean you basically lose all of that
influence to China now right and a lot
of our leverage in the TPP is now
completely gone a lot of that got
removed because we completely left and
now you know a key multilateral trade
agreement that we could have used to
lean into China more for things like
copyright issues and stuff like that
now we just totally gave all of that up
and all that influence is lost to us and
is gained by China which is not good
right in very in in yeah that's a whole
other thing but a lot of the
international like trade related stuff
is very [ __ ] complicated but people
see something like the TPP like oh it's
bad it's like okay and then yeah yeah I
don't know yeah and I feel like Bernie
does a lot of that stuff as well there's
some basic like international relations
stuff that I feel like we'd be very well
served if people just kind of knew and
by people I don't even mean just random
people I mean people who are involved in
making decisions you know like if you
just understand like structuralism which
argues that the most important factor in
how countries are going to relate to
each other is is sort of the that kind
of top level hierarchy and that
relationship rather than the internal
dynamics of whether a country is more or
less socially liberal or whatever the
case may be that it's sort of the the
International structure of nation-states
that is most important you know
liberalism not in the context of
progressivism but just the idea that
countries have priorities which they try
to make effective through domestic
policy there's just like really base
six stuff that I mean obviously Trump
doesn't know it and none of us are
surprised by that but a lot of people
that are on TV commenting about this
stuff don't even know sure maybe yeah I
and I mean that's kind of you mentioned
this earlier that's kind of the
consequence of our four-minute like news
bite cycles right we don't even have
time to get into any of that yeah um if
it's okay with you I've been getting a
bunch of super chats while we've been
talking maybe we'll just see if there's
any interesting ones to answer them yeah
go fight usually when I'm on these shows
and people have super chats usually too
much people saying that I'm like a
pedophile was something so hope it's a
big name in my audience people looking
like oh here's a super chat for ten
dollars why are you talking to this man
lit soy boy [ __ ] Destin
shouldn't you be [ __ ] his girl yeah
but yeah well so here's a good one from
Nate mcbrady who sent for 15 bucks he
says could either of you gentlemen which
I already like the way it's starting
refine the distinction between
controlled regulated capitalism versus
uncontrolled regulate I guess they mean
uncontrolled unregulated capitalism I
mean for me the difference is it's the
difference between the sort of Nordic
economies and a libertarian free-market
utopia which really doesn't even exist I
mean it is that's how I would put two
points on a spectrum to explain to
people the difference between the two
okay so the way the big difference I
would say is it like the like here are
the two most important things okay
markets are real and they work and you
have to acknowledge the power of the
market but sometimes markets don't work
probably fail you have to acknowledge
when they don't work so like for
instance if you want to make affordable
housing happen in the United States rent
control is a real [ __ ] way to do it
because markets are real and market
forces are not going to allow something
like wreckage will ever work however if
you want someone like health care to
work in the United States you have to
acknowledge that for a variety of
reasons there are market failures that
exist in health care that's not going to
work that needs to be socialized right
that's kind of my in terms of like
unfettered capitalism versus like I
guess I got a stock dem approach to
capitalism
yeah and for everybody you know there's
a lot of I guess I would call them
basement economists or I don't know what
term to use maybe that's a little bit
pejorative but there's a lack of
understanding of something called
elasticity of demand and when you
sometimes it's not that the market
doesn't work it's that because the
demand for something like health care is
completely inelastic you either have
no demand for it whatsoever because
you're not sick and therefore whether
the sticker price for a knee replacement
is a hundred bucks or a thousand bucks
or a million bucks it has no effect on
your demand all of a sudden you need a
knee replacement or you need
chemotherapy or whatever and the price
also has no effect on your demand
because you damn well need that thing
and the fact that some of these markets
have inelastic demand it's just like
basic economics and it's completely
missing from most serious discussions of
where markets are I would are even used
the term ethical where there is an
unethical market given in an elasticity
of demand yeah and I mean like
elasticity of demand is only like one
like you've got Geographic monopolies
like you've got different types of like
rent-seeking behavior that have like
favorable legislation that favors
certain large companies like there's a
whole bunch of different things that
could that could be the reason why a
market fails you know and there's yeah I
mean you just need to recognize when
these happen and then you need to
legislate accordingly you know you've
got externalities like pollution for
instance that's not something you have
to pay a price for unless the government
makes you so why wouldn't you pollute
more than your neighboring you know
Factory or yeah there's like a million
other yeah so let's see TV says Tonka's
aw and knobs would destroy both of you
plebs do you know who those people are I
don't know who those people are
yeah tanka saw is like an online
wrestler crazy dude and then no [ __ ]
is a guy that is honestly this is like
operational most inspirational story in
America I have you ever heard this guy
talked before no oh he is astoundingly
stupid unimaginably stupid he will make
you question everything about what you
think the average human is capable of
when you listen to this guy talk but he
has over 600,000 YouTube subs and he's
growing real fast his growth is
tremendous it's insane but yeah should I
check these people out or not um I don't
know I mean if you're like in a padded
room and you don't feel suicidal at the
moment then maybe you can but oh my god
otherwise it's real hard listening to
these people it's fair astounding how
horribly stupid it's funny like
conservatives always talk about like the
you familiar the NPC meme yeah yeah I'm
like NPC number one if you check out
some subreddits okay yeah but like
conservatives are like the ones that do
the same NBC and PC talking points like
how many videos have to be made about
brie Larson like destroying superhero
movies because Captain Marvel was a
bucking woman or
how many times do we have to hear about
like sjw's ruining some franchise
because they put like a black person I
don't know I feel like I hear the same
talking points over and over again from
conservatives I just have this crazy
like anti sjw bend yeah it's like how
many yeah let me see ecto squids says do
you guys foresee an escalation and
attacks from white nationalists I think
they feel desperate and time-constrained
about white replacement uh I mean listen
the last two years tell me unless
something changes we're going to
continue seeing an escalation in
violence from white nationalists there's
a new ADL report which I'm talking about
on my show tomorrow we're anti-semitic
attacks assaults rather doubled from
2017 to 2018 and I'm actually I wonder
if we disagree on this my view has been
that Donald Trump did not create white
supremacists what Donald Trump did not
create white nationalists or
anti-semites but as Richard Spencer
personally told me they see Trump as the
closest thing that they've had in a long
time to someone who will sort of just
look the other way and not aggressively
criticize them and that that's what's
emboldened them I don't know if what
your take is on that um yeah I mean I
kind of agree like I've always said like
Donald Trump is never the problem he's
like the symptom of a larger problem
that has to be acknowledged getting rid
of Donald Trump doesn't get rid of all
the people that were looking for this
type of leader to kind of show up yeah
Pacman's pee girl has a question why did
I post revenge porn of their dad which
I'll deal with uh probably on a paid
only that that's a little too crazy for
what we're talking about here
oh there's wait wait wait wait what you
can't just skip over that and wait is
that a meme or did this happen no it's I
don't know what they're talking about
honestly but I like to pretend that
these are serious things I'll someday
come clean about have you noticed the
videos that hack
Tim Poole has made recently I don't
watch any Tim Poole stuff do you I know
him personally I don't is this a guy
you're familiar with yeah he was kind of
like I don't know like imagine like
David Rubin and Joe Rogan had like a kid
that inherited some of the baldness and
then all the bad ideas and lack of spine
that's like temple right now yeah so you
don't really like his content it sounds
like oh no he's like the most absurd
face sitting like or not face sitting
Christ
Penn City kind of like no position what
was the last dumb thing he tweeted it
was like yesterday
I think even where you just here's like
the like the worst position it's like if
you were to go into a topic and you're
like what is not like what's a bad
position are in okay what is the worst
position I can take on something it
seems like that he somehow manages to do
that oh man can summon to my chattel
know it like something that he just said
like literally yesterday one thing I saw
that he tweeted yesterday which I
responded to was that Dave Rubin is
right not to have Sam cedar on because
if he did Sam cedar would do so poorly
that the left would say you had a week
left is done and I was like that's a
really really in unbelievably stupid
imagine how lost you are to think big
Reuben would win a debate against Sam
cedar I can imagine but actually the the
the temple thing was um it had to do
with not platforming extremists or or
not like um not bending to extremists
and he called progressives extremists oh
he's like see the thing like okay so my
backstory with Tim Poole is I met him
four years ago at a conference and he
was perfectly nice and said he he found
out about me when Westboro Baptist
Church was hacked by anonymous live on
on a show I did I said that's totally
fine and we sort of kept in touch a
little bit and beyond that he's always
been perfectly nice to me but I I'm
aware that he claims to be on the left
or some kind of centrist but the few
things I see him post to Facebook all
seem to be a tax on the left yeah that's
what they always do man though they
always say like it's like me going on my
channel and being like hey guys just you
know I'm cool with Jewish people like
their finer whatever tonight we're gonna
do my my part seventy two of my 800 part
series on how the Holocaust maybe isn't
really reported as accurately as it
really was and then like anytime
somebody like putting like wait dude are
you sure cuz you see and it's like dude
what do you mean I'm just trying to
steal man the argument for a history
revision is I'm about [ __ ] the
Holocaust what's wrong man what's your
problem
tear people do that dumb [ __ ] all the
time and it's you know what the ironic
thing is you wanna know the super ironic
thing is is they're very signaling
that's what they're doing when they say
things like oh well I don't hate X group
like I'm actually really liberal in the
United States I just hate feminism black
lives matter and everything to do with a
Democratic Party and I don't think Trump
is as bad as people make money but I am
a liberal like dude you're virtually
signalling the word
that's not a reasonable position that's
not very reasonable to me actually wait
someone murdered so many times it's not
even a joke would you say it I have to
do a double-take oh god there's somebody
who a couple of times is asking that we
touch on end-to-end encryption and I
don't really know anything about that
like is that something I can are you
able to comment on end-to-end encryption
the coming reality of end-to-end
encryption
my guess is end-to-end encryption means
that like a middleman can't like listen
in the middle of a conversation and pick
up what's going on on either end but
those types of encryption technologies
already exists so I know I guess this
person is saying that it will make it
infeasible to ban child porn and
radicalizing content if there's actual
end-to-end encryption I just don't know
enough about this to be able to comment
honestly oh so what I think what the
donator is act is trying to say is like
let's say we make it impossible for
third parties to intercept our
transmissions yeah do you think that's a
good thing or a bad thing because if we
do make it impossible for like the
government or intelligence agencies to
listen in our conversations can't people
use that for bad like spreading child
porn yes I think what he's saying okay
yeah well I guess I would need to read
up about that just not something you
know I have no problem saying that's not
an area of expertise and I'm I'm the
last person who should be commenting on
that the Homer pimps in wants to know if
either of us would consider going on Joe
Rogan there's probably an interesting
conversation there I've said before I'd
go on and if I did I would gladly tell
Joe what I think is great about his show
and what I think is is not so great and
I've been in touch with this producer
and he actually sent me a message the
other day because we had like a
copyright thing and it maybe we're gonna
make something happen soon what's your
sense do you do you think Joe Rogan is
creating a platform for interesting
conversation is he disproportionately
platforming problematic people like
what's your view so I don't think Joe
Rogan is an extreme conservative or
anything like that I think that Joe
Rogan is probably legitimately like a
son or leaning kind of guy but this kind
of circles back to our very beginning
conversation on like responsible
platforming regardless of your personal
point of view when you're bringing on
like conservative after conservative
after conservative and you make them
seem like reasonable cool people that
are just like down or chill pee
what's gonna happen is some segments of
your audience is invariably going to
peel off and start following those
people he's done it to people like
Jordan Peterson he's done it to people
like Alex Jones like there is only one
issue like you can go on and give like
legitimate well I say legitimate you
gonna talk about like how like maybe we
should exterminate races of people and
as long as you say it in a friendly
manner like Joe Rogan I'll probably sit
there and listen to you and maybe even
agree with you a little bit at the end
of the day I'm being really extreme yeah
but like it seems to me there's only one
issue there's only one issue that Joe
Rogan will fight to the death on right
like maybe black people maybe we can
make arguments for black people being
exterminated maybe the Holocaust didn't
really happen the way that it did you
know maybe we should subjugate the
working class to horrible condition well
did you just say something bad about
marijuana the next hour of our show you
will never insult cannabis in my
presence and he'll actually go real hard
on that issue but that's like the only
thing he'll actually defended the death
so I mean yes I think there's a couple
other issues where I've seen him do
pretty well is these sort of extreme
cartoonish libertarian arguments that
sometimes people make and in fact
there's a day of Reuben thing where Dave
Rubin talks about like chickens and the
postal service and it's just an
incredible implosion and and Joe Rogan
just very carefully and calmly exposes
it on climate change he's sometimes
pretty good when he had Candice Owens on
he really made her look stupid on the
issue of climate change so yeah I mean I
think is it's not that he lacks the
intellectual capacity to challenge any
of the people that come on I think
sometimes he's just under informed and
he even said that like after the first
time he had Jack Dorsey on and people
said whoa like you didn't talk about any
of the serious stuff that should have
been discussed
he actually said I was underprepared I
didn't properly properly prepare for
that so for me it seems just more of an
issue of he's got a lot of interest and
he's not super informed about all of the
stuff he's interviewing people about
kind of yeah that I'm like I don't think
and I could be wrong here I you know if
I'm wrong correct me but I don't think
that Joe Rogan sees himself as like a
journalist or media outlet so he doesn't
necessarily think he has that extreme
responsibility to like the public
discourse yeah so I think yeah so I just
don't think he puts in like the rigor to
actually do that because it doesn't see
it as his responsibility but I mean
unfortunately that it seems like so many
people seem to think that
here we are you know where all of these
people end up platforming all of these
conservatives or like these extreme
conservatives over and over and over
again without challenging them and as
much as you know you want them to be
challenged like I didn't watch the
episode with him in Canada so instead
sprayed if he challenged her on one
issue where like this is a person that
should be destroyed for like three solid
hours like she yes it's so much horribly
stupid [ __ ] that like yeah but I didn't
watch that whole episode so I don't know
how much he called her out on or not the
progressive voice wants to know if you
and I played 1v1 basketball who would
win and I mean let's maybe deal with
that first do you play basketball no you
know and then how tall are you I'm five
foot eight okay I'm also five foot eight
so actually I mean I'm kind of out of
practice so it may actually be a fight
like are you generally in pretty good
shape
um I mean I'm not like huge but I
wouldn't say that in pretty good shape I
can like keep up with my kid and run
around with them but I don't know we can
uh we'll set this up some time ago right
yeah it may be a fight next time I'm in
LA also ask destiny about the veggie to
clip he retweeted it and I think it's
veggie de right I every time I pronounce
it wrong but it's mostly a goof yeah it
happens but but so is there anything
that you want to comment about that clip
you retweeted I don't even know what it
is oh it basically there's like um do
you know anime is yes of course okay
yeah well you say of course but DBC is
one of the most popular anime isn't you
didn't seem to know much about it David
that's true I don't know anything about
that yeah but it's like Saiyans are like
a race at Dragonball Z and Vegeta is
like saying nationalist he thinks that
like the superior things or whatever so
yeah that's just people we're moving in
you're about that clip and lastly I
think a great note to end on is someone
in non-super chat I'm going out of super
chat even though I have no reason to but
I'm gonna go super chat for this what do
you guys think about white people which
is a question on the vanguard of
socio-political thought at this point in
time I don't even know how I answered a
question like that I mean either Jessie
Pierce and try to get me on this one you
love black people
oh that was another thing that temple
had tweeted if you believe in white
privilege you are by definition a racist
I just wear that another dumb temple
tweet but that's crazy I've not seen
that one so I have to say I have to make
sure I say if that's true that's
absolutely ridiculous but I haven't seen
that
that that particular tweet oh sure just
in case I sent it to you if you want to
but yeah he sent that like a week ago
but okay oh and it popped up oh and it
popped up everywhere yeah there we go
there's the link that people want to see
that all right so have what else I think
that this has gone well what what else
do we need to discuss is there anything
else on the agenda that we should be
mentioning um oh man I usually just ask
my chat what they think I don't know if
there's like any other major topic that
we disagree on where are you in
Venezuela I wonder if there's
disagreement there um wait about the
coup that happened earlier today because
I didn't read anything about it or well
just in general I mean did you have a
view of a strong view on what the Maduro
Chavez legacy um I don't know it seems
pretty [ __ ] created by that I usually
follow like local stuff more than then
stuff going on in Venezuela I know a
little bit the only research I did about
Venezuela I had to do with their economy
because I know a lot of people point to
issues with like oh that's why socialism
doesn't work so I was kind of curious
like why their economy failed so I know
a little bit about like the
nationalization of the oil industry yeah
you know the the over-regulation
problems that kind of like out there
over there today but in terms of falling
like the the current regime or you know
stuff going on with Trump in his
relation to that I don't follow as much
now so at least it's fair to say that
you are not like one of these fans of
Nicolas Maduro no I'm there like a lot
of I've seen reactions to this aren't
there a lot of like lefty people that
are kind of like championing him and
saying well the u.s. is only trying to
kick him out because this is capitalism
versus socialism something like that
yeah and then some people are getting
mad because they're kind of excusing
what are probably human rights
violations of this guy because he seems
to represent yes yes yeah I mean so far
your limited perspective matches up with
mine which criticized on a lot a lot a
lot of YouTube channels I've never heard
of but seem to be very strong in their
positions that I am very very wrong on
this issue yeah I try not to I try not
to talk a lot cuz I like I like I kind
of like I've seen some of but I haven't
like dug in I usually on a lot of these
issues it used to be that I would like
give a take on something and then I
would get a million people emailing me
with like history PhDs telling me why I
was wrong so I tried to be really
careful before I talk about an issue so
I would like read a little bit more
about it to figure out like what the
with the best position to take oh so I
don't really comment much on oh yeah
that's perfectly fair and I think it
should be lauded
to do that rather than saying how is it
that destiny is not commenting on this
he's telling us he's not read up on it
as much um he wants to and I think that
that's great we it would be great if
that happened on more shows can you
imagine if during these like internet
blood sports things someone said you
know in the middle of it respectfully I
feel like I'm not as well read on that
issue as I would like to be to comment
so I'm gonna pass on that one that's
where the format falls short because you
can't really do that in those six way
for our you know in sports
ironically it's actually one of my
weakest points is because if somebody
confronts me and something that I don't
know I'll say like oh I don't really
know as much about this like I'll do
that openly but the people that I debate
are never doing that so it actually
gives me the appearance of looking very
weak when I do that like some guy like a
guy will open up and talk a whole bunch
of [ __ ] about some [ __ ] that he is
totally [ __ ] uninformed about without
a problem in the world and I'm not
usually willing to do that so sometimes
that makes me look like I have the lower
hand in a debate yeah alright well
listen this it's it's been a very
interesting 70 minutes yeah okay hold on
so we can talk more later about this
there is a twitch show that is totally
unrelated to politics but sometimes to
do politics just because I'm on it yeah
and the guy the guys name is train
wrecks I don't know that matters to you
but sometimes he hosts like really big
political debates where he's able to
surprisingly pull on people that that
are sometimes pretty big in terms of
doing these debates would you be
interested in joining me on one of these
if I if I do this in the future or this
would be like you and I versus him and
someone else type of thing not him in
someone else but two other people oh
okay potentially like really big name
people coming up for the next one like I
can show you like you would be
interested in these people
yeah interests in the part about yeah
okay yeah I mean what do I know what
I've just gotten myself into but why not
okay oh and did we want to talk about
sam harris or not yeah I mean listen I
have no I have no idea what what your
position is on Sam Harris so I'll just
like lay it out in 30 seconds and then
you tell me whether it needs to be
expanded I think that Sam Harris is work
on mindfulness and meditation is
fantastic and that's pretty
uncontroversial and I sort of consider
him along the lines of Jon kabat-zinn
there and I think that that's just one
side of him which is how I originally
knew him which I find super interesting
and I
he's a great person to listen to I think
there are on political conclusions that
he comes to a pretty broad range of sort
of agreement and disagreement that I can
encounter I think his framing of some
issues related to Islam I agree with I
think he sometimes states factual
uncontroverted incontrovertible truths
about the circumstances of world
religion and I think other times he
either deliberately or sort of by
exclusion gets people thinking some
pretty pretty horrible stuff and I also
have a real problem with the way that he
handled the bell curve dude with
relative kid gloves I thought that that
was maybe the worst thing that he had
done if I could do this I can think of
it did you listen to his conversation
with I came I pressed recline about that
I listened to part of it and I remember
Ezra making some pretty good points yeah
and it was it was pretty pretty
compelling yeah Sam oh man Harris was
not heed the published emails that he
thought would put him in a good light
his yeah he was horrible in that
conversation I have a lot of problems
with Sam Harris and in that it's
actually similar to Jordan Peterson
where sometimes he just talks about
stuff that he just probably shouldn't be
talking about I don't know why he does
he gets into some like really weird
Islamophobic territory sometimes right
and like the distinction I always make
is like I hate Islam and I hate
Christianity but I don't [ __ ] on like
Muslims or Christians right like you
have to be able to draw a distinction
you're like you know we can all hate
religion together because you know we
have problems with theology but that
doesn't mean that all of the people are
bad or that all the people that follow
that religion are bad and and Sam gets
caught up into these weird areas
sometimes real like he's like he was
like one of the Four Horsemen atheists
and sometimes I get this feeling that
he's like defending judeo-christianity
and it's like really weird and yeah so
yeah I don't know
I just I have a lot of problems with
with Harris's politics seems like for
the most part he's typically
left-leaning like progressive but then
sometimes he gets into these weird like
fence sitting areas where he's like
channeling like the Jedi spirit of Dave
Rubin and yeah I don't know I just I
really don't like his politics sometimes
well I mean to go back to what you were
saying before do you feel that he is
arguing in good faith yeah I really
think he tries to I just think he gets a
little bit lost on some issues sometimes
like I
I think the conversation him and Ezra
Klein is perfect where Klein is like
very reasonably laying out the case
we're like hey this is why what you're
doing is like really bad and kind of
dumb and Harris like totally can't see
it and yeah I highly recommend everybody
to watch that that conversation is
really good I think all right so it
sounds like we're not like crazy far
apart on the issue of Sam Harris sure I
also hate his philosophy and everything
yes tea with philosophy is hilariously
stupid but that's another thing yeah
okay basically what he says there's like
bad stuff is bad because it's obviously
bad and good stuff is good cuz it's
obviously good that's his oh so this is
like from the moral landscape I guess
yes yeah yeah yeah I've only like Papes
thumbed through it a little bit okay
yeah you've got about as much value out
of it as you possibly may be so I'm not
I don't need to go back to what you're
saying no you don't well listen let me
know about this 2vs2 debate thing
because it sounds it sounds interesting
like have you so when you've been on it
before who what was like the lineup um
it was supposed to be Sargon of Akkad
and do you know who Stefan Molyneux is
yes I do he actually has attacked me a
few times on my views on race and IQ
interestingly yeah he blocked me on
Twitter I hate that guy but he ended up
bailing out of the conversation I don't
know if it was I'm gonna say it's cuz I
was involved because that guy's Dec
telling me a lot in the past but yeah he
ended up ducking out so it ended up
being at the last minute it was Star gun
of a cod and a guy named Nick Fuentes
which in retrospect that's probably not
a good idea but it was like an hour to
go are you familiar with that kid at all
I've actually heard about him and wasn't
he recently like caught doing something
incredibly stupid who are you thinking
of Jacob wall
no no I know Jacob all I know the
difference between the between the two
but I thought that Nick one says or no
you know what that some video came out
recently of Nick Fuentes saying
something horribly racist it was like
somewhat like a friend's video or
something like that I don't even
remember now oh maybe I tweeted a ton of
[ __ ] like making fun of him for that
because he's one of those people that
tries to hide his like anti-semitism
behind like other words yeah oh yeah
well I semitic it was a video where it
was something related to jews yeah you
know now that okay maybe you might have
actually saw my tweets maybe but i'm
yeah he does like a lot of stuff like
that it was him
there are a couple dog whistles i don't
know if you if people are familiar these
but here's a couple dog whistles will be
alright
mom one is people talking about like
cookie factories I guess where people
talking about like hi you know like I've
got a friend and they said they baked
like you know 6 million cookies but if
you look at like their house and you try
to calculate how many ovens they have
there's no way they could bake that many
cookies and the callback is like oh you
know obviously that many Jews could have
been killed in the Holocaust because
it's not possible there's that one and
then um have you ever heard people
talking about the pit bull problem no oh
sure so somebody will make a video and
innocuous video people like Nick cuentas
or Brittany vents you've done this name
it could be doing like hey pit bulls
you know despite being only 10% of the
population commit 50% of the attacks on
other people now I'm not saying pit
bulls aren't dogs do you see where I'm
going with this yes I do I told you yeah
yeah yeah people did yeah they're yeah
he engages in like a ton of dog whistle
e stuff like that and then there was
that video that was leaked of him saying
like oh you know I don't think there's
anything you know or if you're a white
person and you want to [ __ ] a black
person you can do that it's just
degenerate like bestiality is it was
like the court I think that he had but
so that's the guy you debated along with
sargon of akkad the other day and who
else was on your side on that one um do
you know Hasan [ __ ] oh yeah yeah we are
you in New York are you in LA you're in
New York I'm in Boston Oh Boston okay oh
you should have we should aside share at
PAX East when we were in Boston but oh
yeah yeah that's true but yeah well
listen it sounds in extraordinarily
sophisticated what's going on in that
channel but I would love to participate
sure yeah the next one should not have
like I don't want to platform people on
that tier of like Nick Fuentes that was
like a last second thing so hopefully
like aim for bigger people we were
aiming for Blair white last time - but
then she bailed as well but yeah I don't
know right no of course not she's
liberal what are you talking about her
oh I thought that no I are you kidding I
actually no I'm sorry I'm kidding it's
she's like my low where they say their
left-wing but they're basically just
like token figures that people on the
right use to [ __ ] on trans people or gay
okay yeah that's what I thought that's
that's always exciting yeah okay good
well listen next time we'll do a
minute-by-minute analysis of Candis
Owens's new program which is endlessly
fascinating if you haven't seen it I
recommend that you check that out wait
on what I don't know Fox News or
something isn't I think it's like a
Prager you show or something like that
oh god yeah there's another bad faith
actor that can just totally be dumped
from the internet nothing of value would
be lajas supposedly I was debating her
March 18th and I it's a story for
another day but in any
no debate is currently scheduled I think
is the most important sort of top line
top line from that all right we've been
speaking with destiny a Steven bunnell
now located in Latin Los Angeles I don't
know why I kept sending you Central Time
because you're actually on Pacific time
but I used to be I used to live in
Nebraska the last time we talked about
MLA speak now so you know must be why
all right man really appreciate it
appreciate you joining me and love love
doing this oh cool yeah I appreciate it